now this morning we are hearing from  locals who are stranded and frustrated  trying to make it back home here to Las  Vegas Adam Burke and his wife went to  South Carolina for the holidays to visit  family the plan was to return to Vegas  Monday night but like so many other  Southwest Travelers they're stuck and  they say the only available flight  getting back here to Las Vegas departs  on Saturday  honestly at this point I'm so eager to  be home that I would seriously consider  a one-way car rental and just driving  across the country for however many days  it takes  and while rental car options are scarce  Amtrak trains and Greyhound buses you  know those certainly are options but  those tickets are selling out very fast